je suis gré en voyant et une en tant que
le son de ma voix je c'est là un exemple
par n'importe comment mais c'est pas
grave je suis en train de devenir un
petit peu espagnol venons à l'accent un
peu russom je suis voyant j'ai la
réponse à la question que tout oppose
trois filles et un peu brésilien mais
voyons ne rigole pas car j'ai même la
réponse à la question que tu ne t'es pas
encore posé et nous allons la poser
ensemble pour ça j'ai besoin aide
numérologie à mots clés sinon fabien
olicard c'est à distance je te demande
de penser à ton âge maintenant tu penses
à ton âge maintenant et tu te concentres
sur le dernier chiffre de ton âge si ton
âge ses 112 ans qui pense qu'à 2 citons
hc 16 ans tu penses à 6,6 ton âge ses 50
ans pas bien tu prends le 5 secondes à
ge ses 30 ans pas bien tu prends le 3 tu
plan le dernier chiffre de ton âge sauf
sauf si c'est 1 0 - en clair prenez pas
le zéro quoi je prends aussi dernier
souffle de mon âge le neuf
parce que j'ai 29 ans on ne rit pas sur
l'âge du coup l'envoyant et tu va
multiplier le dernier chiffre de
tournage parts
le dernier chiffre de mon âge situe à 22
ans tu fais deux fois 9 si tu as raison
tu fais trois fois 9 57 ans cette fois
neuf nous sommes en train de croiser
deux destins maintenant numérologie tu
vas réduire le résultat que tu as dans
ta tête qui tourne résultat assez 14 tu
additionne 1 et 4 pour faire 5 jusqu'à
temps n'avoir plus qu'un seul chiffre
dans ta tête tu comprends la logique de
la numérologie croisés et maintenant
écoute moi bien c'est très très
important
tu vas enlevé cinq at-on résultats mais
si tu peux pas enlever cinq sites ont
résultat final c4 alors tu ajoutes 3 tu
enlèves 5
et si c'est pas possible tu ajoutes 3 et
tu as maintenant le résultat de notre
destinée croisé numérologique alors je
vais afficher la liste des questions
possibles pour cette voyance en ligne
voici la liste des questions regard de
la question qui correspond à ton
résultat et je vais essayer d'y trouver
la réponse l'est la question qui
correspond à des résultats dans ta tête
et je crois avoir la réponse
oui j'ai la réponse à ta question pour
ta bonne et à la chaîne il suffit de
cliquer ici
juste là
et bien la réponse à ta question alors
fait le fossé avec le dimanche c'est
toujours quelque chose qui vous permet
de bluffer vos amis et bien c'est le cas
vous allez pouvoir les bluffer en leur
faisant ça alors vous faites votre liste
de questions à vous avec votre point
d'interrogation sur une petite feuille
de papier par exemple vous mettez vos
questions et vous fait faire à la
personne exactement la même chose que ce
que moi je vous ai fait faire attention
pensez bien à prendre le 9 comme
multiplicateur c'est la clef de tout ce
tour qu'on a fait ensemble là juste à
l'instant faites vous à vos amis cette
semaine bleue fait les amuser vous
abonnez vous profitez bien de ce
dimanche et rendez vous demain à 17
heures pour le prochain mentale blog
ciao
numérologie numérologie je vais arriver
à le dire
attention je peux jeter attention' et
faisons une numérologie croisé croisés
je suis un petit peu partie maintenant
un peu plus dans le sud de l'europe et
fabien olicard le voyant à tous les
accents s'il veut